we want the community to build this we
want it to be their worlds we want them
to tell their stories and their game i
think it's human nature to navigate
uncharted territory to find a place
where we're free to explore to be
creative and to share amazing
experiences
the goals are to make an experience
that's unlike any other which is such an
exciting thing to be part of i think
ultimately like that's kind of been the
big ambition is to create this kind of
like open world that can be built out in
every direction i think it's every day
is a new discoveries and it's constantly
growing we've put a lot of focus i think
on the current zeitgeist and what it
means to represent yourself digitally
this is more than a game it's a labor of
love it's a labor of passion
the dream is to create a whole new world
for the next generation of gamers and i
think that we've we've kind of captured
that
players will play a massive part in this
it's not going to be just our game it's
not going to be just what we decided to
do with it there's something in it that
will definitely appeal to you no matter
what it is that you love to do the
really thrilling aspect of all this is
that people get to see what we're doing
for the first time i'm just so excited
for people to see what we've been
spending the last five years pouring our
hearts and souls into and i'm excited to
see how they feel about it even though
they will have to wait just a little bit
longer everywhere has become more than
just a video game for us and today we're
delighted to give you a peek behind the
curtain at what we've been working on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go everywhere and i'm sure
you've got a ton of questions and
joining me now from build a rocket boy
is adam whiting to hopefully answer some
of those because
we're a little confused but we want to
know a lot about this so tell us uh
everywhere what kind of game is this
what can you tell us adam well firstly
going to say it's really exciting to
just be here and we've been looking
forward to coming out of stealth mode
and really delighted to start the
conversation today here at gamescom
now i won't be able to reveal everything
but what i can say is that really we're
not trying to make a normal game i think
the scope and ambition of this project
are quite unlike anything else we want
to build a whole new world for gamers
and not just a place to play but watch
share create hang out with your friends
and so much more
well i gotta say the end of the trailer
i think we all were taken aback by whoa
change art style this seems totally
different is that part of everywhere
what can you tell us
well jeff that's one of the many
surprises we've got in store for players
i mean we are passionate about
making games and telling stories but
ultimately we made everywhere to be a
place where players can make their own
experiences be who they want to be and
tell their own stories but we're still
passionate about making immersive and
cinematic experiences that players can
just get lost in and enjoy
i guess you say we want people to have
their cake and eat it and everywhere is
the place that can happen all right well
definitely a bold uh vision for what
you're doing here uh the other question
i'm sure we're all wondering is we
didn't see any date on the trailer any
sense of when we're going to get to play
this thing where are you at in
development well i'm delighted to say
that we aim to have everywhere in the
hands of players in 2023 but we've got
many more things to show and tell over
the coming months and we're really
excited for you to sign up on our
website everywhere.game but really today
was just a sneak peek behind the curtain
to see what the team has been so hard at
work on and we're really excited to get
this in the hands of players as soon as
possible amazing well adam thank you for
sharing the reveal here at gamescom it's
awesome to have so many european studios
on stage and tonight we've got a lot of
european studios that can reveal their
games for the first time and right now
we're going to move to another world
premiere announcement